so so I had this somebody told me this
crazy story did you cuz polar bears are
well the most vicious and I heard that
you literally maybe had some alcohol one
time and we're running on a beach where
a polar bear was eating there I was it
feels like a bad idea it was a terrible
idea it was in a movie with Barry Pepper
I love you know Barry Pepper Great
Canadian actor um and uh it was up in
like Churchill Manitoba I think and we
were drinking at the rap party I think
God help me I think all of this do I
think I think and uh and then I think in
the moment we're like you know what we
should do we should like race down the
beach and uh so me and him and another
guy came we came running down this beach
and a guy that lived there just started
swearing literally swearing at us and
just screaming I mean screaming bloody
murder buzz kill yeah yeah but cuz we
didn't realized we were running to our
certain death because there were polar
bears all down the beach and yes they're
the most aggressive God but they're so
cuddly
beautiful those Coca-Cola commercials
they like snuggle so that is true I did
that like I sometimes I wonder about
that how close I was to being like a
little polar bearch yeah well who would
have thought there were just polar bear
nobody ever hears that oh there's polar
bears hanging on the beach it just
doesn't happen well yeah up there was
amazing we used to rent these little
Zodiacs um J uh H oh my God why can't I
remember his name he's such a beautiful
human being James Cromwell yeah remember
James Cromwell he's such a wonderful
character actor you might remember him
from babe remember that'll do pig yeah
and he and I used to go and yes give it
up give it
up I'm I'm trying to know are we
clapping for James or the pig or that'll
do or just that I remember that all
we're just happy in the new year um but
we used to for it was like 40 bucks and
we would go and rent a zodiac and go out
and all these little beluga whales would
follow us good times oh that's
beautiful yeah you know no that's
beautiful it's important for me to get
out of the city and experience stuff
like that for my like emotional state
it's so cool everyone in your audience
almost everyone literally at the same
time just went a except one dude right
there and the Beautiful great
good-looking dude and he did this like
this he's like that sounds horrible
man
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home